[Music]
hit an interview with Fox and Friends
earlier today President Trump said he
gets along with broad Rosenstein gave
credit to mark Meadows and others for
exposing what is happening with the
Russia witch-hunt take a look I actually
get along well with rod we have a witch
hunt going on which is disgraceful and I
have to tell you I'll take these
Republican guys with Mark Meadows and
Jim Jordan and gates and Gibbs and all
of them I hate to mention a few names
because there's so many of them and I
want to give everyone of them glad these
are tough smart guys they know there was
no collusion it turned out with Russia
there was collusion but it was with
Hillary Clinton the DNC
these Republican folks I think they're
becoming folk heroes these are great
great people and they want to get to the
bottom of it I agree with that the
freedom caucus they stand by their
promises they fight congressman mark
Meadows joins us right now Fox News
investigative reporter Sarah Carter the
hills John Solomon congressman we now
have rod Rosenstein let's see he
recommended firing Comey he signed the
last FISA warrant the third renewal
application and this is a guy that
appointed Muller now we have three
people saying that he seriously was
talking about wearing a wire to invoke
the 25th amendment but cage said it
watch before the Cape said at least a
page said it let me think of the other
ones one other person said it Jim Baker
Jim Baker that's it
yeah yeah I tell you the reporters that
you have on I'm with two great reporters
that have done tremendous work in on
this front but I think probably the
biggest part is is the president is
exactly right there is no collusion he
knows it I know it even the Democrats
know it and it's about time that Bob
Muller he must finish the investigation
it's time to call it quits because what
we're starting to find out or the wheels
are coming off
Glenn Simpson Fusion GPS Glenn Simpson
refused to come before Congress I talked
to chairman Gowdy this evening the only
option we have now is to hold him in
contempt of Congress why isn't that
happening and where are the 302s that
the president was going to release what
where are the FISA warrants that he was
going to release well we've got we've
got to get those out transparency is
good medicine Shawn as you know I've
been advocating for that the president
has been advocating but he wants to be
cautious and I applaud that you know
he's getting accused left and right of
interfering in this investigation
interfering they're obstructing
congressional investigations that's your
constitutional role which to your credit
you're doing a Sarah Carter oh I
couldn't agree more with you Sean on
this I mean look we have rod Rosenstein
obviously a lot of information has come
out in the last few weeks we know that
James Baker the former general counsel
of the FBI came forward and said look we
took seriously what he said he wanted to
invoke the 25th we now know where they
want to either that's right and we
secretly record the President of the
United States beyond that we also know
that there were two other people
apparently speaking with rod Rosenstein
I give the president credit for this
shine the president is a great chess
player I think he's making his move now
I think that the president came out he's
been talking to rod Rosenstein we don't
know what happened on that flight we
don't know exactly what they spoke about
during those 30 minutes but the
president is looking and watching and I
absolutely believe that there were other
people inside this administration that
were with rod Rosen Stein on this and I
think it's going to come out I don't
think it's gonna come out next week
but I think eventually the president
will make that public if he's smart and
then he'll get rid of rod Rosenstein
he'll get rid of Jeff Sessions he'll put
other people in place this is what I'm
hearing behind the scenes this usually
will happen all right so Lisa page John
Solomon says for nine months they had no
evidence of Russia collusion just before
the appointment of rock rod Rosenstein
and Muller and then of course even Peter
struck said there's no there there now I
think with their media leaks strategy
that we've them we've been able to
unveil and report along with the
insurance policy comment they leaked the
information to different news so let's
go back all goes back to the Clinton
phony
dossier they leak it all over the place
to create an atmosphere that oh there
must be so much happening this really
happened when just the opposite is true
the only Russian interference came from
Hillary paying for Russian lies that
were disseminated to the American people
and used as a fraud on a FISA warrant
court four times yeah listen there was a
lot of Harry Houdini going on in May of
2017 at the Justice Department
they knew they didn't have a case and
instead they tried to create the aura in
the public media that there was a case
and it was being obstructed by the
president and I think when we look back
in history we're gonna see a lot I was
thinking today and because of the work
of Congressman meadow congressman Jordan
those who've been digging we now don't
think two years ago this month
Glenn Simpson and Christopher Steele
were out peddling their story to the
media trying to get it out before the
election clearly showing their political
covers two years later Glenn Simpson
can't even come anymore and testify to
Congress because he has to invoke his
right against self-incrimination how far
has this investigation turns employ
collusion on Russia to collusion with
the Democratic Party in the FBI and it's
because of people like congressman
meadows and Congressman Jordan that
bucked the trend and when you and
Senator Gregg and others you guys all
deserve credit to what did I call the
this year the year the boomerang quick
question all of you will we get the
Declassified and redacted materials mark
meadows yeah I think we will get them
hopefully sooner than later before the
election hopefully a small group of them
before the election and we need to have
them Sarah yeah absolutely we need the
dossier we also need the gang of eight
packet which will expose the exploratory
evidence that's real to the American
people and the and the 302s of John will
we get them real quick absolutely no
doubt about it before the election
either good some of its gonna a lot of
it will be after the election I fear huh
all right thank you all for what you're
doing